Hi, everyone.
In this lesson, we're going to go ahead and make our own MPC
and create the materials to be able to edit and tweak them
the way that we need to to be able to bring it back
into Sequencer and to have it fully animated.
So let's get started.
So in Unreal, I'm going to show you some tips and tricks
to get things going so we can actually
start from scratch from Sequencer
and be able to blend things the way that we need to.
There's a few things we do need to consider
when working with the MPCs.
You'll see that I already have a material called
M underscore MPC demo, and we're
going to go ahead and look at that in just a bit.
I want to point out some things between specular and rough
that we need to keep in mind.
All right, so let's go ahead and make our MPC material
a node.
So we're going to go to a material,
and we're going to go to MPC material parameter collection.
And it's down at the bottom here.
I'm going to click on that, and let's go ahead and call
this one MPC underscore new demo, hit Enter,
and I'm going to double click on it.
And you'll see we have a relatively clean slate here.
And we're going to go ahead and add a couple scalar
parameters, hit that twice, and we're
going to create one color vector parameter.
There we go.
And in here, I'm going to go ahead, and each one of these,
I should say, I'm going to go ahead and say what they do.
Now this one's going to be my spec amount.
The next one, open that up.
This one's going to be my rough amount.
I'm going to point out how these work because it's
easy to forget this as we go through materials.
You've taken all the material classes.
But spec and rough work very different from each other.
And the fact that one is on and zero is off,
I should say, basically be at parallel from each other.
They're different.
And in that, when they are like that,
you can actually turn one off and turn one on
if they're underneath each other.
So spec can actually influence your rough
if you're not careful.
But in our case, we want spec to complement our rough.
And I'll show you how that works.
So I'm going to go ahead and go to the last one here,
the color, and we'll call this color control.
There we go, cool.
All right, and to keep it consistent,
we'll just keep these guys together.
I'm going to go and hit save on this.
And we're going to go back to our MPC demo.
Now, if you don't know where that's at, it's right here.
Just double click on it, it'll populate.
Now, I don't have this in the class here
because I wanted to be able to actively demo this.
So you can actually see how this works.
If it's just sitting there, it might be a bit confusing.
But if you want to make one really quick, you can.
And I simply just went in here and created my material.
And I built a texture for it.
Just hit the T key again and loaded a simple dirt texture.
This is if you just want to follow along.
And in that, I created a blend overlay, a multiply,
and a simple scalar parameter,
and a couple of scalar parameters
so I can demonstrate the difference between
a spec and rough when it comes to having them fire
and be on when it comes to sequencer.
Let me show you what I mean.
We'll pick on these guys first.
So these two fellows work very differently from each other.
And what I mean by that,
let me go ahead and disconnect my roughness.
Now you'll notice immediately when I disconnect my roughness,
it's not quite as shiny.
We see that they're complementing each other.
But we'll notice that if I disconnect my spec
and reconnect,
and you'll notice there's still a little bit of spec
going on because default spec is 0.5, it's kind of halfway.
If I reconnect, put my rough in here,
you'll notice, hey, we got shininess.
And then if you reconnect our spec,
you'll notice, oh, it's a little bit more shiny.
They're complementing each other,
but there's a difference between on and off.
When it comes to rough, zero is on.
When it comes to spec, one is on.
I know it's a bit confusing,
but the problem is if we start to animate this in Sequencer,
we could actually get our numbers
and not quite get the values we exactly want.
You can actually play with these in such a way
and have them initially set to be on within your MPC
if you wanted to.
So in our spec, we want to actually reverse these.
We want spec to be zero and we want rough.
And you'll notice when I hit zero,
rough is automatically turned off.
That's not fair.
So that's because rough spec will influence rough
and mess things up.
We want rough to be also off.
And when he's off, he's set to one.
So we want to set these guys both in that,
sitting with that and those numbers.
So let's go to spec and set that to zero.
It's already there.
And we can set our rough already to one.
Now, if you want to, you can make this negative.
Now these are just scalar parameters.
And I did a test on this
and this actually worked okay to keep this at one
if we wanted to.
You can try keeping it at zero,
but you'll have to play with those numbers in sequencer
because remember it acts differently.
One is on and zero is off
in the case of when you're looking at spec.
So spec one is on, zero is off
and rough it's opposite of that.
One is off and zero is off.
So that's where it can get really confusing.
I'm putting myself in a place so that they're neutral.
And again, they can influence each other.
I should say at a starting point
where they're just not on
and they can influence each other.
So if I go to spec and turn this back on again
and then I turn rough back on again,
you can now see just how bright and shiny they are.
Then if we go to specular and turn it off
and notice that mutes are rough, that's not fair.
We'll have to completely disconnect it
to be able to get rough to come back.
So this is what I mean by you gotta be careful.
These guys are gonna push and pull on each other.
Not necessarily the most ideal,
but when you're animating in sequencer,
you have to keep those things in mind.
All right, let me disconnect these completely.
You actually just delete them.
Now, when it comes to color,
the information also is not treated the same.
We created an MPC.
Let's go ahead and save our properties that we have
and let's go and drag that MPC into our scene.
Now, this MPC, we need to let Unreal know our intentions.
So in this case, we're gonna say
this is our color information.
Now, this color information, if we wanted to,
we can do several different ways
to blend things together,
but we can't just go in here
and create a multiply and connect it
because the way that this information is parsed
is not like a regular constant vector.
So if I go in here and put this in,
oof, you're gonna get an error, right?
So it's not gonna digest that information correctly.
So one way around it is we can create a blend overlay
and create a color amount.
And it can be a texture if you want to,
or it can just be a simple shade if you want.
In this case, the blend overlay
is handling our stuff a little bit weird.
It's actually pushing through the texture information
according to like you would use
a blend overlay in Photoshop,
but you can choose whatever you want in here.
I'm just using this as a demo.
We can make things a little bit more color overlay
if we wanted to.
So a blend color if we wanted.
We can do a color burn, a color dodge.
You can totally do that if you want to.
So I just wanted to point that out
so you have those options,
but I'm just gonna keep this one the way it is for now
and we can even just swap it out with this simple texture
so we can see it a little bit better on screen.
Okay, so we need to pull in the MPC again a few more times.
So let's pull in the MPC one
and then also just control D two.
This is gonna be our spec and rough
and we're gonna create a multiply
for each one of these, multiply and multiply
and we can go with here
and let's set this first one to our rough,
or I should say spec amount.
And the next one's going to be our rough amount.
And since we're using dirt,
let's go ahead and get a simple dirt texture in here.
I'm using this without normals.
Normals are gonna be complimentary,
but we're just gonna use the texture black
and white information for the spec.
Load that to the top there
and that's fine like my sample.
So at least it's consistent.
Pull them to specular and pull this across
and we'll do the same thing with our rough.
You have the M key or control D in this case.
Pull this in the bottom, not a multiply,
I should say scalar, right?
Pull this over here
and we'll duplicate the texture one more time.
We're totally cheating.
We need to duplicate the texture, not use a scalar.
So let's do control D.
I'm gonna show where our mouse is at.
Swap these out a little bit
and let's go and plug these in.
Plug this into the A channel
and plug this into the B channel.
There we go.
And pull that right into the rough.
Now again, we're not getting any information here
for our rough here is set to one
and the scalar one is set to zero.
So just keep those things in mind
when you bring them into sequencer.
And we're gonna go ahead and save that information.
In our case, we could just hit apply
so that it's updating
and we can decide whether we even like it or not
cause we may not like it.
It's up to us how that works.
All right, so now let's go ahead to our scene
and in our scene, let's go and load a sphere.
So I'm gonna go and load a simple sphere.
We'll go to basics
and we'll go to our sphere here shapes.
There we go.
So let's go ahead and load a simple basic shape.
Let's go to sphere.
There we go.
Let me go ahead and move this sphere over
and increase its size so you can see it better.
Now what we wanna do is load a few things.
Let's actually first apply our material to our sphere.
There we go.
In this sphere, we wanna go ahead
and also load those objects in our sequencer.
So I'm gonna click on the track here.
I'm gonna add actor.
Let's grab that sphere.
And then let's also add underneath our MPC effects here.
We can actually go here to add another MPC
or actually this is a better way.
You go to track
and you go to material and primer collections
and we can find the one that we have
called the new MPC demo.
There we go.
So let's click on that.
And we see that we have the new MPC demo there.
And with that set in,
we wanna go ahead and edit some of these.
Now let's actually go to the first key frame
for the rain hit.
And we're gonna hit that plus parameter.
We're gonna load the rough amount.
It's gonna auto key it for us.
Hit that plus parameter again.
And we're gonna load spec amount,
hit that plus parameter again,
and load color in there.
So we're keying all of those for MPC
and we can open it up to see them keyed.
So as I drag it across,
we go all the way over here.
We can now change our color information.
So we can increase the red if we want to,
just a little shiny red.
And you'll see it actually works pretty well
with that blend overlay.
Now again, the blend overlay is gonna react differently
like in Photoshop,
depending on what your material and texture is like,
but that just showed you one way
to be able to blend them.
We can now go in here under spec amount
and we can increase or decrease things
according to what we need.
Now, if you want to,
we have it set default to one,
we can set that to zero
and we can do spec to one.
And you'll see we actually have it nice and shiny
and they're complimenting each other.
Notice that spec was turning everything off.
So we can now have that all key framed in here
and we can now see this sphere start to change color
and get wet in our scene.
Pretty cool.
All right.
Well, that's about it with this one.
Hope this makes sense to you
and helps you kind of navigate using MPCs.
Materials are very tricky
and the fact that you want to make sure their state
is in a neutral state or a nice starting point
to bring them into sequencer
and to get them to read accordingly.
Notice we're not controlling the range.
So you do need to know your numbers ahead of time.
So just keep those things in mind.
That's it with this video.
In the next video,
we're going to look at some more materials
which can really compliment your scene such as subsurface.
Thanks again.